in this episode of cloud performance
atlas I helped some IOT devices find
their long-lost friends is friendship
the best configuration for performance
stay tuned to find out one of the big
challenges with IOT devices is that
there's a tendency for each device to
use a different set of protocols for
communicating with other devices around
them this is where I ot exchange comes
in their product is somewhat like a
dating app for IOT devices where a
device can find other local devices that
communicate on similar protocols their
system was running on a federation of
vm's inside of google cloud using
persistent disks to host relational
databases that they were using to keep
everything in sync sadly after some
profiling they realized they weren't
getting the performance they wanted out
of the disk itself now if you remember
persistent disks are the ones that
aren't physically attached to your host
vm hardware and they come in two flavors
standard and SSD that each one has their
own performance characteristics which
unsurprisingly matters a lot for your
usage configuration now for persistent
disks in general performance scales as a
function of the size of the disk the
bigger it is the faster it is we can see
here that for a standard persistent disk
the IEEE opsin throughput scale pretty
well in relation to the size of the disk
SSD persistent disks show the same
behavior although the numbers are
significantly higher however SSD
persistent disks also have performance
scale with the number of the CPUs that
the VM has or as the the docks a SSD
persistent disk performance scales
linearly until it reaches either the
limits of the volume or the limits of
each compute engine instance which was
where the IOT exchange folks were
running into trouble their VMs didn't
have enough CPUs for the IEEE ops they
needed to their SSD pd's by moving them
from eight core to 32 core machines they
saw their I up performance almost double
you gotta love it when data saves the
day if you'd like to know more about
today's topic check out the article
listed in the description below and
don't forget to check out the rest of
our cloud performance Atlas content on
YouTube because when it comes to
performance every millisecond counts